welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain is my pleasure to introduce
you to dr. James Matt and dr. Karen
David dr. David and dr. NAT have been
principles in shaping the investigative
functional neuroscience part of brain
initiative from its inception in 2014
both also hold responsibilities and
systems cognitive and computational
neuroscience and inds
the neurology Institute of NIH dr. David
comes from a background in molecular
biology and genetics and has served the
brain initiative in various capacities
including his program analyst project
officer scientific review officer and
her current role as program director dr.
not enjoyed more than two decades of a
research career and sensor motor
cognitive and quantitative systems
neuroscience before going to NIH in
addition to a program director position
with NI NDS he is a co-lead of the team
of trans-nih program officers in the
understanding circuits part of the brain
initiative for complete biography on our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
dr. Knapp and dr. David will be
presenting on NIH brain funding
opportunities NIH brain initiative and
funding and functional human
neuroscience my name is dr. Annika
Shannon and I will be your moderator for
today's event I am delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab woods we would like to
extend our special thanks to the brain
initiative program directors for their
efforts in organizing today's session
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions in
the drop-down box
our speakers will respond to your
questions on your presentation the
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credit
tab located at the top right corner of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
without any further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. James Matt and dr.
Karen David dr. David thank you all for
joining us
I'm Karen David and along with my
colleague Jim knot we represent the
brain initiative we'll be describing
brain finding opportunities and
understanding the circuit basis of
behavior with me focusing on those four
non-human animal studies and do not will
be focusing on those supporting
functional human neuroscience so what
should we expect from this lab roots
neuroscience symposium for the first
tract in addition to an overview of the
brain initiative we're excited to have
our brain supported investigators
showcase their work on functional human
neuroscience the second track tackles
the neuro ethical considerations of
human neuroscience research as led by
our colleague Saskia Hendrix and various
experts in the field and the third track
to be introduced by our colleague Nick
Lang goals will showcase innovative
neurotechnologies in line with the goal
of the brain initiative to accelerate
the development and application of new
technologies lastly a better
understanding of brain circuitry and
networks has the potential to shed light
on brain disorders and so the fourth
track will focus on clinical updates and
what should we expect for the first half
of this 30-minute brain overview I'll be
providing an overview on what brain is
all about its vision funding priorities
and budget and then the bulk of this
talk will be on the specific funding
mechanism supporting circus related
projects and as part of the talk is
geared towards investigators who are
curious whether the brain initiative is
a good fit for the project they have in
mind
then I'll close
by describing ongoing activities with a
brain initiative and provide you with
more resources if you'd like to learn
about the brain initiative so what is
the brain initiative about let's start
with the very first sentence from the
document brain 2025 a scientific vision
written by brain working group which is
made up of representatives of the
scientific community the human brain is
the source of our thoughts emotions
perceptions actions and memories it
confers on us the abilities that make us
human while simultaneously making each
of us unique such a simple statement
belies the challenge that comes with
trying to understand how the brain works
how do the diverse set of cells their
synaptic connections the neural
circuitry anatomical and functional the
dynamic patterns of activities how do
all leaves give rise to behavior and
towards this grand challenge of
understanding how the brain works the
brain initiative aims to accelerate the
development and use of tools for
acquiring fundamental insight about how
the nervous system functions hence its
name brain research through advancing
innovative neurotechnologies
brain has a particular focus on circuits
and networks with goals to map the
circuits of the brain measure the
fluctuating patterns of activity flowing
within those circuits and to understand
how this interplay leads to cognitive
and behavioral capabilities so that the
bold goals of brain will be tractable
the brain working group identified seven
high-priority research areas that span
multi levels of analysis touching on
cell types circuit diagrams neural
activities interventional tools
computational tools human brain research
and the integration of all these
technological and conceptual approaches
to understand the brain and towards this
high priority areas ten
NIH institutes had worked together to
design these diverse programs and
initiatives to stimulate these areas of
research I'm noting here that in later
slides I'll be describing in detail the
funding opportunities under integrated
approaches and all the programs offered
here and the science we fund are made
possible by continued public support and
we are very much grateful for the public
support that enabled the ramping up of
brains budget by almost 10 times from
2014 to today the ramping up of funding
that you see here has enabled us to
expand the number and scope of programs
to meet the various high priority areas
and this sustained long term commitment
is meant to attract talented researchers
from multiple fields as well as
stimulate interdisciplinary
collaborations which will be key to
advancing the goals of brain so this
talk is part informational and part
advertisement as we hope to entice
talented scientists out there to check
out what brain has to offer and
particularly what we have to offer in
terms of funding opportunities and I'll
be describing a set of initiatives
focused on supporting projects with a
goal of understanding the circuitry
basis of behavior in line with program
priority number seven our brain team
offers a suite of funding opportunity
announcements or fo ways supporting
research that integrates experimental
analytic and theoretical capabilities
for a comprehensive analysis of circuits
and systems we offer several funding
mechanisms to support research at
various stages from exploratory to
mature projects and also at different
scales from single projects from single
labs or small teams to large
multi-component programs led by big
teams and for more information please
contact us as this email
brain circuits at NIH gov and please
note that in some of these other ways
foreign institutions and components are
allowed so let's start with the r34 the
r34 mechanism is our entry-level to our
research project grants and this funding
opportunity is meant to support the
exploratory efforts of individual or
small multi Pi labs to enable them to
apply for a future brain erawan and this
is a two-year award meant to support a
limited scope of aims and approach for
establishing feasibility validity or
other technically qualifying results to
support a future brain our own project
and we've seen applicants use these
mechanisms as an avenue to be creative
and try out high-risk high-reward
approaches to improve how neuroscience
questions are answered but the r-1 is
meant for more extensive elaborated
goals with feasibility data and we are
interested in projects that are
conceptually and technically innovative
meaning projects that are tackling a
basic high-impact question in systems
neuroscience using cutting-edge
approaches in brain 2025 states no
single researcher or discovery will
solve the brain's mysteries the most
exciting approaches will bridge fields
linking experiment to theory biology to
engineering tool development to
experimental application human
neuroscience to non-human models and
more in innovative ways and we've seen
this coming to fruition the best in our
team research funding opportunities
where we encourage researchers with
different expertise to come together to
solve a neuroscience problem using an
approach that is multidisciplinary and
that which bridge scales we also have
two versions of our team science fos
targeting different stages of the
projects the three-year you will one is
intended for exploratory projects that
to develop experimental capabilities and
quantitative theoretical frameworks and
to form teams in preparation for a
future u19 application the u19 is larger
in scale and is multi-component meaning
that programs can come in with two to
five projects and at most twist resource
cores and we do require to course the
administrative and data science course
for studies that include basic
experimental investigations with humans
only the u-19 mechanism will accept such
applications because we have a funding
opportunity specific to that type of
research which Jim not will talk about
we also have a funding opportunity
devoted to theories models and methods
which I won't be describing in detail
here brain is also committed to
promoting diversity and to training and
supporting the new generation of
transdisciplinary brain scientists
towards this we offer a k99 our zeroes
our program and supplements now this is
a colorful busy slide which is meant to
just illustrate the diverse topics and
approaches that we're supporting and
this is important to note especially
when you're sending in an application
the expertise of the panel of reviewers
will be diverse given the diverse set of
topics that I just showed you and this
will be important to keep in mind when
you are considering the audience of your
application and to potential applicants
it is also worth paying attention to the
review criteria that is specific to the
particular fo way that you're targeting
we encourage bold and adventurous
projects but this needs to be balanced
with feasibility and these applications
are reviewed in special emphasis panels
rather than standing study sections and
we usually have just wanted to receipt
per year and brain has no defined pay
line so we make our funding decisions
based on the following criteria and also
because if this our funding
deliberations take place at several
levels as you can see here it starts
from the brain teams and the next level
would be the coordinating team followed
by the multi council working group and
then attend Institute councils and
ultimately the decision is made by the
ten Institute directors so that's all
for our funding opportunities and I
would like to point out one last thing
as I mentioned brain is nearing its
second half and so a working group is
reviewing progress of the various
programs towards the different
scientific goals of the brain initiative
and the goal would be to identify new
opportunities for research and
technology development and the report is
expected to come out this year and for
brain enthusiasts this would be
something to watch out for
so now concludes this part of the talk
and to learn more about brain I highly
recommend checking out our websites or
emailing us for more information I'll
turn it over to my colleague Jim not ok
thank you Karen let us just do a
transition here ok so let me start out
by returning to this slide the Karen had
presented earlier and what I'm going to
do is focus on this part of the spectrum
of funding opportunities that focus on
human neuroscience and a little bit on
our integrated approaches so in the
bottom left part of the slide there we
have
tracts for our specific human
neuroscience studies one of them is a
technology and device development track
and I'll describe that in a little bit
more detail here in just a moment and we
also have what we can describe the
research opportunities in humans which
is to understand functional neuroscience
in humans and then we we do have also
featured today later today one program
from our large unite team
multi-component team brain circuits
programs are you 19's and I'll get to
that here in just a minute so in terms
of our human technology development
funding announcements there is a
portfolio of funding mechanisms that
span the track from doing concept
clearance up to clinical trials and as
you see it here early on in that process
there are small programs two-year r21
programs called brain new concepts and
this is a funding mechanism to help
support the proof of technical concept
and proof of technology early starts in
the development of new devices and new
technologies following that there is a
five-year ro1 mechanism called the brain
new technologies program and that is a
program to support novel discovery on
technology and devices for the study of
the human brain following that there is
a program called the brain devices
optimization which uses a cooperative
agreement a uo1 program and the goal of
that program is then to take
technologies that have been proven have
been successfully developed and go
through a process a very deliberative
optimization of that and these are
milestone driven kinds of projects then
following that there are a spectrum of
programs to make the final transition
through the IDE application program and
up to clinical trials that you see there
called the brain next-generation device
and the brain next-generation devices
with there's these I and alphabet soup
there of mechanisms and I'll talk just
briefly about those in the next slide
but I would guide you to the NIH brain
website and also the contact their neck
Lange goals who you will actually hear
from later today
nick is one of the leaders of this human
technology program for the brain
initiative so that's a good contact for
you if you have questions about that so
then I will turn your attention to our
research opportunities in humans
mechanism this is a program to support
innovative in vivo human neuroscience
research that is enabled by intracranial
access direct access to the brain for
recording and stimulating the idea of
this project is not so much to support
disorder or disease therapeutics that is
the domain of the NIH Institute's the
goal here is to support model or
hypothesis driven fundamental discovery
in experimental neuroscience in human
neural science we use this program to
support multidisciplinary teams and
multi-site recruitment in order to
enable high-impact questions in human
neural science with the awardees from
the the the ROH program we have formed a
consortium workgroup with the idea of
identifying consensus standards of
practice and neural escalations and in
the next slide I'll elaborate on that
just a little bit
the consortium in part looks at at
issues about how to collect and share
data for ancillary studies using the
data that are collected as valuable data
they're collected from these human
studies they work on standardization for
data and dissemination among the wider
research community and importantly work
on some neural ethical considerations
you only hear more about that later
today within this consortium
we have a sub group called the
neuroethics worth workgroup and the
unique aspect of these studies that are
supported by this program is we have
investigative mechanism research and
patience that does not necessarily offer
direct therapeutic benefits to the
patient so there are some special neural
ethical considerations for this these
are projects that piggyback on to
standard of care for for example say
epilepsy disorders but the the research
studies then are added on to those and
there are questions about how much
additional risk is acceptable beyond the
standard of care that enables the access
to the brain there are also issues about
informed consent of these patients
patient altruism and the possibilities
for recruitment coercion and we will
have a group actually addressing those
issues later today there are also issues
about the conflicts of interest for the
physician who serves as both the
caretaker and the experimenter for these
investigative studies so then just to
finish up I return to Karen's portfolio
of programs there and I emphasize down
in the bottom right that we're going to
talk about the we have invited guests to
talk about their the research
opportunities and humans awards and we
have one of our large multi-component
u19 awardees that is doing multi species
studies that is both human and non-human
primate studies and it will be one of
the talks that are featured later today
and in fact that is I'll talk by Beth
Buffalo there at the top of this slide
on how the human brain learns to learn
just to tie things up the things that
you will hear from our Roh awardees
today from our speech and language
component of our awardees we will have a
talk by Mark Richardson who will talk
about coding of speech production we
will have a talk provided by Mike
Beauchamp who is it has an audio
visual speech is part of an audio-visual
speech project that he also will
actually be talking about some tool
building efforts that he is also funded
to do through the brain initiative from
our sensory and motor awards within the
roh space we have today talks by not a
parade Ian and Ashley fine singer is
particularly talking about Sumner o'the
ethical implications under the auspices
of this Ward about basal ganglia
function in humans and finally gen Colin
jure will also be presenting later today
and Jen works on BMI issues in direct
access to brain control from our
executive and cognitive functions
category of the ROH awardees we will
have a talk later today by early rush
hour who will talk about human memory
and a talk from Sameer chef who will
talk about human prefrontal cortex so
just to finish things up on behalf of
Charon myself Josh Gordon and the rest
of the NIH brain team we are glad to
have you all listening in today and hope
that you are interested and challenged
by the data that you're going to get
from our awardees later today so I think
that finishes up our our presentation to
introduce this thank you doctor
that was very informative we will now
begin the question and answer portion of
this presentation as a reminder please
submit your questions by clicking on the
ask a question box on the far left of
your screen we will address as many
questions as time a lot slower so let's
begin with the first question dr. Gordon
stated that all data must be shared what
will that look like who will have access
to what and how so that's a complicated
question with a complicated answer so we
are working very hard within the sub
domains of the different aspects of the
brain initiative
to have reasoned and reasonable data
sharing policies that will be useful for
the research community as well as do
things like protect the intellectual
property and the personal information
about patients so our programs are
designed not an all-in-one policy but a
policy that the data needs to be shared
is paid for by public funds and we are
creating multiple ways for that data to
be shared in reasoned and reasonable
ways we do have a number of awards in in
the area of data science that allow for
data archives data analysis and data
definitions so that is also part of the
awards that we have in the NIH brain
initiative is the brain device
optimization inclusive to small
businesses and startups yes I did go by
that quickly but there is a small
business component to the device
development part of our human
neuroscience and in fact there are
public-private partnerships that are
enabled there are partnerships with
several participating device
manufacturers that put in place
creatives and other other useful things
for investigators to partner with those
commercial entities and come up with new
applications so there is a small
business portion to to that program boy
that is an interesting question we don't
that I know I formerly have a program
for that but that is certainly a
challenge to us with an interesting
question that would be quite valuable
thank you how does the transdisciplinary
training work the transdisciplinary
training I assume that is addressing the
issues
of early career training
so we have the k99 r00 program that
Karen had described before and that's a
transition program that is designed to
take people in the later stages of their
post doctoral programs in a min turd
situation to get a certain amount of
progress made and then that is
transitioned into the what's called an R
zero zero award which is a research
award that the candidate then uses in
the transition to a first faculty
position in fact it's a very valuable
negotiating tool for getting a new job a
new faculty job we also support
diversity programs for training and an
early career we support diversity
selection among our awardees across the
board in the brain initiative how
efforts from the NIH brain image to
better understanding of human diseases
and disorders oh yeah so we specifically
for the most part designed the brain
initiative to do what the Institute's
are not so most of the funding for the
specific diseases and disorders of the
brain and the nervous system go through
the various appropriate Institute's so
the brain initiative focuses more on
device and technology development and
fundamental biology understanding of the
brain under the premise that and tell
you understand departs lists and how
those parts work that is a has to come
first before we understand the most
effective ways to address the
remediation of diseases and disorders
integrating postdocs coming from non
life science
absolutely we encourage applicants and
participants from outside of the
neuroscience areas especially with our
emphasis on tool building we are
particularly interested in getting
engineers computer scientists and
physicists certainly a physicist for
example or an engineer is welcome to
apply to one of the training programs or
to one of our our grant application
mechanisms we also encourage with our
team-based awards that the teams that
are are put together are
multidisciplinary and so they would
naturally bring in people from the the
quantitative sciences and and psychology
behavioral and cognitive neuroscience so
that is absolutely encouraged within the
brain initiative what would you suggest
to a bachelor student in order to be
able to do research in this field in the
future what are the main things we
should focus on besides neuroscience for
example is programming with our Python
and important skills game we believe
very strongly that quantitative and
computer science skills are an important
part of what a biologist does so the
answer to the question about learning
computer languages as yes you'll find
that's a tool you'll use nearly every
day so I mean what was what was the
first part of that question row what
would you recommend what would you
suggest to a bachelor student in order
to be able to do research in this field
in the future what are the main things
besides neuroscience right so
neuroscience is a an area of biology so
you can't know all of biology you need
to focus on where your interests are is
it cellular neuroscience is it systems
neuroscience is a cognitive neuroscience
but besides getting a focused education
in in a narrow area it's very important
in neuroscience as a trans discipline
study of science is that you get a
exposure to a broader way of approaches
and techniques one of the fun things
about neuroscience is that you never
stop learning new things new information
and how to apply those to the important
questions that we ask in neuroscience
thank you so much
thank you dr. James Knapp and dr. Karen
Devine we are out of time if you have
any other questions please look to your
email as our presenters will be able to
respond to them by email later on I
would like to thank our wonderful
audience today for all your incredible
questions and coming up next please join
us as we welcome the brain initiative
awardees will present on site to make
the updates and research on EWTN's
division of the brain initiative see you
there
thanks to all